Wow
[Music]
one thing you can buy off eBay is a
total strangers school yearbook that
usually cost you around ten to thirty
dollars so they're not super expensive I
bought yearbooks from five different
decades in 90s 80s 50s 40s and 30s if
you buy somebody's old yearbook it comes
with all the messages that their friends
wrote to them the most popular thing
people wrote in the yearbooks when I was
in school was hope you have a good
summer we're gonna see what people who
have passed wrote in their yearbooks and
what kind of people owned these
yearbooks my first year book is from
1993
it's from Florida the eBay listing said
that it had lots of nasty writing in it
lots of obnoxious comments and that's
exactly what I wanted I see devil horns
drawn on a teacher I'm noticing a lot of
the handwriting is the same I think the
person who owned this yearbook wrote
messages to himself dear me you are the
greatest looking guy I think you are the
greatest looking guy in the world love
yourself you are so cute love yourself I
mean I guess it's nice to I can't even
it's too sad okay I found some real
signatures from other people one of them
says you're the ugliest most
pain-in-the-butt cool guy I know okay
stay cool love always I feel a little
bit bad for this guy not a lot of
friends wrote in this yearbook which I
can relate to I remember just having
like a couple close friends signed my
yearbook and then having just a lot of
space left which is totally fine but I
definitely remember that feeling where
you're like wow my yearbook should be
covered in like messages and inside
jokes from all my many friends oh wait I
don't have any this yearbook is from
1982 and it's from Georgia
these people wrote a lot of message I'm
so glad we've got class together this
year I love you to death because you're
a really super guy you're a very nice
person and I know for sure nothing will
ever change that how can you be so sure
love you Haley
look Haley people change okay you are
one of the nicest guys I know call me
sometime
this is a whole page written by someone
where do I begin
you've meant so much to me I love you
dearly when you make that first million
you ought to drop by and pay me a visit
okay now this just seems like fishing
for money you know I love you even
though I do pick on you all the time and
if you didn't know you do now these
people are so friendly if not a little
faint almost all of the messages for
this 80s guy are about how nice he is
how good a friend he is but then there's
just one message that really makes me
doubt all of that hey how you been I
haven't seen you much I'll never forget
the time you poured coke down my bathing
suit and iced and tied my hands together
at Shane's party you are really a sweet
guy good luck always what and I get sort
of like having a food fight tying of the
hands that's what really makes me
question how nice this guy is but okay
our next decade is the 50s this yearbook
is from 1958 from someplace in
Massachusetts
to Joe the kid who always had to have a
smoke in driver's ed so apparently Joe's
nickname was smoky possibly because he
smoked if anyone has a sense of humor
it's you you're a doll - Joe that
wonderboy with the girls and - caused
mr. Wigan to have ulcers - Joe the boy
who always bothers me in class between
his jokes and actions he is one boy to
watch out for a boy to watch out for
yo a boy who really knows how to tease
this guy from the 50s was really good at
math the brightest most intelligent
genius math student - Joe the smartest
math student - Joe a kid who always did
his math homework so I could copy it I
know how copying is wrong but I feel
like there's a certain selflessness of
just being like yeah the homeworks easy
for me you can copy it I don't care I
respect that even though it's wrong
honestly the guy who owned this yearbook
seems kind of cool this yearbook is from
1947 in New York a girl owned this
yearbook
best of luck always lots of luck lot's
of luck best of luck good luck lot's of
luck lot's of luck best of luck
lot's of luck lots of luck to you always
sincere wishes and lots of luck best
wishes best luck to a swell girl to a
swell girl cheers for girl to a very
suave
good luck and best wishes to a swell
girl a lot of people sign this yearbook
they either say good luck or you're a
swell girl or good luck to a swell girl
maybe the girl who had this book just
was was that swell and needed that much
luck so last year book is from 1935 it's
crazy that this yearbook is more than 80
years old a young man owned this book
in Illinois there's a section that says
athletics and there's just a tractor I
mean I'm from the Midwest but I know
that a tractor is not a sport there's
lots of signatures in here but people
just signed their names not even a good
luck not even to a swell boy this is
just a bunch of names so people didn't
really write personal messages in this
1935 yearbook from Illinois there's
something sort of desperate about a
yearbook like these are the special
times you must remember and then you
look through it and it's like these
pictures don't really reflect any actual
thing that happened you're supposed to
write something meaningful for your
friend and their yearbook and you're
just like what do I write I don't know
stay cool you're a swell girl best of
luck like there's nothing
to say it's kind of like signing a
greeting card you're just like ah it
doesn't matter what decade it is no one
ever knows what you're supposed to write
in a yearbook so that being said please
I hope you have a good summer have a
good summer and stay cool
[Music]